so morgan um i know you're a huge harry  styles fan i am so we have this one for  you olivia wilde will see him dancing up  a storm as she cheered on her bow at his  recent concert stop in toronto so cute  let's see  [Music]  it what's up  are you  are you rick rolling me i'm i'm modern  rick rolling you  it's like the new version  of being rick rolled  so wait there's no hairstyle you're  welcome no no oh okay that was the stick  guys all right so in honor of uh this  brick wall we're actually going to leave  you with rick astley who's never going  to give you up which has most definitely  tested time as they recently recreated  the music video 35 years later for aaa  insurance commercial take a look uh  we'll see you next time this will be a  deal breaker hey  i don't know they're good moves  [Music]  is this still a thing